alors comment ça va thing comme si comme
sing un post racing quand même vous êtes
à ping est là comptant thing près mieux
serait un desing qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter que ça du ring voilà
j'avais le trac est un peu là le
tracking là maintenant ouais non pas du
tout non ça se voit à quoi vous pensez
ingla moi personnellement là ouais je
pense à une prof de maths que j'avais en
terminale qui s'appelle madame baradat
ling non madame baradat non je veux dire
son vrai nom qui m'a fait chier pendant
trois ans et qui est ma façon tu feras
jamais ce métier on ne verra jamais à la
télé je sais qu'à regarder beaucoup
france 2 le soir donc voilà je peux dire
je les emmerde sur france 2 où ben oui
mais voilà alors franchement mais bien
fait chier voilà c'est fait
basée à way est ce que vous pensez que
souci c'est rond ping si on revient sur
nos horaires de tout à l'heure ça fait
longtemps que non cela dépend ding ouais
vous avez un des footings majeur mois
ouais je suis gourmand ah oui ben moi
j'ai moi j'ai du mal à l'empêcher xingda
racing de bowling ah ouais ah oui ça
marche pas ça se voit ouais ouais
qu'est-ce que vous avez mis une bonne
bouteille pourtant déjà arrêter la clope
c'est pour ça oui mais pas bien sûr
comment tu vas attraper le cancer avec
la boue peut-être avec le grill ou non
les ogm c'est plus long mais j'ai
confiance vraiment préféré la radine
goût le télévie zing mélange inc
mélangez vous ai appris quoi dans ce
métier à connaître dominique farrugia
qui fing acquis fingerlings et qui fing
vous écris vignes beaucoup c'est
beaucoup une proviseure thing
c'est moitié moitié heureusement vous
êtes je voyais un meeting tout à fait un
meeting avec plaisir c'est juste à côté
en fer blanc
ouais c'est vrai mais assez 1,50 mais
dans ce taudis de merde c'est au studio
500 c'est ça quelle horreur
c'est l'euphorie ces deux villes
sur tbs du tout les soirs et le madame
michaud sur l'énergie entre 6 heures
de toi car